[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how about this shot this is a good job
fighting over the screen good job
contesting
that's just
the heat a lot of the offense is that
mid-range game butler out of bio hero
anthony
anthony not only
under four to play seven point game
malik buck long three-pointer that's
good
from way downtown
westbrook drives kicks it out anthony
anthony off the bounce at the oval finds
bradley bradley fires it up
he backs it up
and it's a three-point game
westbrook charges goes in here a lamp he
cracks it in one point game
westbrook
one-on-one with bam adebayo pull-up
jumper
lakers lead
[Applause]
lake is up to
hal
westbrook off the switch gets to his
spot elevates knocks down
the mid-range jumper
kyle lowry looking cross-court to pj
tucker tyler hero off the bounce gets to
the foul line falling away he ties the
game
tyler hero how about this continue to
make plays dribbling the basketball
tough contest doesn't matter
westbrook brings it up
drives up tucker gets inside
fall back it's good
back-to-back buckets from west from
timeout miami the lakers backed up by
two
russell westbrook
trying to find his game trying to find a
rhythm
back big time here in the home crowd
hero gets free two pointer for hero
shout out pj tucker on the follow to tie
it
maybe i should have changed my shoes
mike during the course of my career are
you kidding me pj tucker turning back
the hand of time
big time put back and finish
you know we talked so much about lowry
being the perfect fit for the heat how
important is he now with all the
injuries they've had
out of fire with the deflection and
steel throws it ahead to hero
[Music]
hero on the drive back on a file for the
flush
26 points 10 rebounds four assists for
bam mata bio
[Music]
malik monk at his best game as a laker
so far puts up a three
monk comes
[Applause]
double-teamed by tucker
throws it up and in
malik with the floater just shot by
malik
talked about it
he feels like no one can defend him and
that's good defense better offense for a
guy that's been rolling all night long
wow
lowry throws it inside out of mile
westbrook ahead the davis he bounces
here with the lakers in his best game
early in the season and a beautiful pass
westbrook to davis 14th assist through
russell westbrook 24 points now
for anthony davis
lowry on the drive goes right at monk
finds out a bio out of shuffles bank
shot is good and the foul
miami's still alive and did he have a
timeout left
your camel after you make this shot the
mindset of the lakers is do we commit a
foul in transition making sure they
don't get three
lowry to inbound
cross-court hero gets a clean look
stumbled and puts it up
one goal rebound deadman back up and
he's fouled fouled on the floor with 2.6
remaining
what they need to do he's got to hit the
first and miss the second absolutely
and another missed free throw
and that will seal it oh well we've seen
some crazy things it's the rim ball
tapped out but bradley has it that'll do
it
lakers hang on and win in overtime and
what turned out to be
a terrific game here at staples center
oh well we've seen some crazy things
it's the rim ball tapped out but bradley
has it that'll do it
lakers hang on and win in overtime and
what turned out to be
a terrific game here at staples center